If the US or North Korea had a Facebook page,
each country would change their status to
“it's complicated” now.
It's not what we had as recently as 2017 when
Trump was threatening to go to war over and
over again with North Korea.
They will be met with fire and fury like the
world has never seen.
Now they are not only on speaking terms but
literally sitting in a room with each other.
We will have a terrific relationship.
I have no doubt.
Chairman Kim and I just signed a joint statement
in which he reaffirmed his unwavering commitment
to complete denuclearization.
The problem with this is that Trump and North
Korea have very different views about what
should be accomplished when you denuclearize
the Korean Peninsula.
The US wants North Korea to give up its nuclear
weapons.
North Korea wants the United States to stop
isolating it diplomatically and stop cutting
it off from international markets.
In theory, there is the makings of a deal
there.
For Trump, denuclearization means something
called CVID: complete, verifiable, irreversible
denuclearization of North Korea.
They give up their nuclear weapons and the
US will always be able to make sure that they
have gone away.
However, for North Korea, denuclearization
of the Korean peninsula mean something completely
different.
It means, sure, North Korea gets rid of its
nukes, but the US also withdrawals all its troops
from the Korean Peninsula and ends its
alliance with South Korea.
This has been unacceptable to every American
president in the past.
We will be stopping the war games, which will
save us a tremendous amount of money, unless
and until we see that the future negotiation
is not going along like it should.
What seems really good for North Korea is
really bad by American standards.
There's just not a great middle ground that
could actually roll back North Korea's nuclear
program.
No country with a nuclear program as advanced
as North Korea's has ever denuclearized.
A 2017 estimate from the Defense Intelligence
Agency concluded that North Korea probably
has up to 60 nuclear weapons.
It also has ballistic missiles that could potentially
hit the American homeland and potentially
a nuclear weapon small enough to fit on one
of those rockets.
National security adviser John Bolton floated
an idea for dealing with North Korea that
he called,
the Libya model.
So this is to reference an agreement struck
with the Bush administration by then Libyan
dictator Muammar Qaddafi to give up his nuclear
program.
However, Qaddafi's program was way more limited.
He wasn't really even close to a bomb.
And, perhaps more to the point, about eight
years after this agreement was struck in 2011
the US backed an uprising against Qaddafi
which killed him.
To Kim, Libya is an example of what happens
if you trust the United States too much.
It's an example of what happens if you give
up your nuclear weapons.
The main reason they want them is to deter an
attack.
Ideally, they want to deter any war from starting
by making the war seem really scary and really
dangerous and really bloody.
Normalizing relations is something that I
would expect to do, I would hope to do, when
everything is complete.
Normalization is a prize from North Korea's
point of view.
It would mean a US embassy in Pyongyang, a
North Korean embassy in Washington, ambassadors,
formal diplomatic receptions.
And like I'm saying this and you're probably
imagining that sounds ridiculous and you're
right.
Because it's North Korea.
Unwavering commitment to the complete denuclearization
of the Korean peninsula. This is the document
that we just signed.
It's hard to imagine the endgame being some
kind of big big deal.
What's more likely is nothing changes or things
get worse again.
I think he’s going to do these things.
I may be wrong.
I mean I may stand before you in 6 months
and say, ‘Hey, I was wrong.’
I don’t know that I’ll ever admit that, but
I’ll find some kind of an excuse.